happy Friday reject nation we have a new
trailer on our hands
called the happy time murders official
restricted trailer for my understanding
this trailer played before certain
Deadpool to screenings we something that
pulled - we were gonna shoot a review in
a couple hours we did not have this
trailer play at our theater nope that is
for sure yeah I'll be talking about this
one because this is like the talk of the
town at a cinema con I'm excited to talk
about this because a lot of people are
raving about it before getting into this
got to do a page from the day shout-out
for Erica Tuesday Eric Erica Tuesday is
one of John super close friends also
been a loyal patronage act for quite
some time erica has constantly invited
me to tag along to go to this jacuzzi
she has in her backyard for months I've
been saying no and then one day my
girlfriend and I said yes well go and it
was dubbed bomb and it was one of the
best times ever
so Erica thank you so much for being you
and sharing your soul with us and more
importantly sharing your jacuzzi yeah
and I mean you know and Eric is also a
Muppet lover which makes this a perfect
little Mon yeah yeah yeah thank you for
the puppeteer in her own or just the
nusiance we could just go with that name
sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a [ __ ] FBI
[Music]
I'm not doing this do it
[Music]
oh sorry about your dead human friend
[Applause]
oh that is not at all what I would
expect they're gone full team America
about this oh my god I'm I'm like
shocked I never thought I would have to
think about that about puppet projectile
ejaculate mm-hmm yeah because I heard it
was like an RV him buffets movie yeah I
heard that the director of this did some
previous like legit Muppets
family-friendly films that's Jim
Henson's son Rick funny like okay I'm
sure they're not going to cross a
certain amount of money r-rated like
hardcore for some reason none of the
information that I learned about this
hearing that it was like an r-rated
movie and that there was vulgarity and
crude here like the stuff I heard about
it before watching this
none of it prepared me for like nah whoa
this is this is so [ __ ] shocking like
I said I mean I could fathom the idea of
an adult Muppets you know an r-rated
Muppets you know III they already tried
that show where they were going for like
a more you know grownup sensibility but
yeah this was nowhere near what I was
expecting and even reading the premise I
mean I think the premise is cool cuz it
kind of reminds me of like a Roger
Rabbit or something yeah you got
somebody going around actually killing
Muppets from his old show yeah that's a
murder mystery cop detective story with
Muppets and a whole lot of rot I thought
it was like puppets for summary I didn't
realize this was like legit the Muppets
hard hard yeah yeah like legit Muppets
films I thought this was a film with
puppets yeah I know but not Muppet from
his I've worked on the Muppets
I was awareness is a red bam but I just
wasn't prepared I'm like shocked I mean
it looks really funny if I could just
digest this for a second it's the first
time in a long time I actually want to
see him loose McCarthy movie I'm glad
that if you're gonna do it r-rated
muffets movie that they're going it's
going pull out hard are with it a
hundred percent using that opportunity
I don't always laugh at jokes in
trailers but the jokes we got here and
like the banter based things they have
that tag at the end after she wakes up
from snorting in their guesses [ __ ] me
the timing on that was so good I haven't
been bowled over with laughter by a
trailer in for everything I guess the
only thing to think about now is it's
shocking if you're not like prepared for
like a hard-r Muppets I don't know if
anybody else is shocked like how how I
was feeling I was like what the hell I'm
so surprised let's the skater Jackson
one if you've seen meet the Feebles
you're not shocked
so I guess went for the actual viewing
experience though a big part of the
effect of this trailer was the surprise
value of that I'm wondering if once this
process is with someone like me and then
I go watch this movie will it still
actually be funny and surprising you
know that's that's the big that just
comes down to the writing you know yeah
I mean at least based on this it
certainly looks like it's gonna deliver
but yeah I mean like it is a bit of a
juggling act I would that was that you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification BALCO subscribe
buttons don't really work keep a lookout
for a Deadpool to review this weekend
and check us on patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly q and A's would
love to have you become a patron oject
today